la première fois en baisse la lumière on
ne bouge pas promoting emmanuelle b g et
verbales à dire non mais marc edouard
balladur a été un passé fait pas bouger
eh bien oui mais pourquoi si on
recommence on rallume la lumière à cause
des doigts à la creuse un c'est pas à
cause des doigts attention un deux trois
réussi suis là à devoir arrêter un pas
qu'on me dit dans l'oreillette que
c'était un eczéma ou chez vous non plus
alors emmanuel comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voit on va faire une femme
une première fois encore mon premier
souvenir
votre premier souvenir quand j'ai
embrassé un garçon derrière le
préfabriqué à kobe avait trois ans très
précoce à la deuxième question c'était
premiers désirs mais j'ose pas vous la
posez pas ce que c'était c'était le même
premier rendez vous amoureux c'est
encore le malawi je me sens mieux pêcher
c'était le même âge et à la pêche
j'avais 12 ans on n'empêchera j'avoue
que c'était le même
c'était dans une église ou j'embrassais
roger mais avec la langue avec la note
technique ou de foot c'était roger
première passion c'était roger médisance
euros j'ai quand même il eu du pot les
premiers réveil à deux ce n'est pas
roger quand même deux premières fois
vous êtes réveillé à deux avec un
versant dans un lit et là c'était au
pensionnat de maisons laffitte
ouais et je me suis endormi et voilà
c'était je me suis réveillé dans
l'internât des garçons
le premier week-end à 2 alors que les
autres c'était premier premier week end
à deux hommes s'étaient c'était avec
roger
et oui oui il m'a dit en angleterre oui
c'est que ça dure et vachement paris
choisit alors premier chagrin d'amour
c'est roger edwards edwards
je suis à l'opposé la victoire aux et
non non c'est que pour vous mais roger
là il veut expliquer que c'est pas lui
non mais bien de cela et malgré ma vie
esquivé cris râles fait malgré ce qu'il
écrit il faut voir ce qu'il est en rouge
et roger ce formidable j'ai apprécié mes
doigts reprise de la meilleure les a
réunis ce soir
risque
ben voila voila complet d'abord j'ai
ensuite edouard très bien donc première
votre où tout ça c'est du roger chagrin
d'amour c'est roger aussi je sais pas
j'en avais tout le temps à ouais j'avais
à nez en trompette des taches de
rousseur et ils m'ont tous abandonné
donc j'y vois les mecs
tel 05 gradins bourg permanent première
rupture
j'avais 4 ans quatre ans c'est jeune je
venais de me marier
ouais devant un arbre ah oui oui non
midi j'aurais aimé vous connaître j'ai
divorcé un premier divorce c'est
toujours pareil pressé d'aller mon image
ça qu'on fait entre trois et quatre ans
emmanuelle béart a vécu tout ce que nous
en a mis 40 ou 50 ans à vivre quoi
première envie de vous suicider première
envie de me suicider j'avais six mois
je me rappelle pas envie quand même oui
bien sûr comme tout le monde j'imagine
c'est pas eu envie de me suicider vous
méritez plus vieux j'avais 32 ans
et qu'est ce qui vous était arrivé
chagrin d'amour chez classique un bon on
encaisse sentimentale bon et loire j'ai
subi de vous poser la question à vous
aussi est ce que vous avez envie de vous
suicider une fois dans votre eau tout le
monde on a envie géré comme un humain nu
albert 95 comme ça n'était pas assez
important pour ça très bien bonne
réponse on rallume la lumière